[Music]
hello there the free-to-play Behemoth
honai star rail has made its way over to
PS5 over the last month I've been
playing and I'm so impressed with its
characters its RPG elements and its
combat that I asked hoyo verse to
sponsor a video about it and they said
yes now let me tell you why you should
add honkai star rail into your trusted
rotation of
games honkai is a free-to-play
roleplaying game from the same devs who
created genin impact and immediately
throws you into a Sci-Fi story on board
a space station that's attacked by this
Sinister Legion amidst all this chaos we
uncover our main character for the story
known as the Trailblazer I chose the
girl version because I'm a guy in real
life slight issue here she's had her
memory seemingly wiped we then join the
crew of the astral Express and
Intergalactic space train and begin plan
Planet hopping following the story
filled with unexpected reveals and
double
crosses the main reason I keep coming
back to honai is down to the combat
turn-based fights akin to Classic Final
Fantasy games where each team takes it
in turn to beat The Living Daylights out
of each other yet there are multiple
strategy elements to be considered that
make fights feel earned and losses feel
like lessons star rail gives each
character an affinity to an elemental
type from fire to ice from lightning to
Quantum this element directly impacts
fights as the enemies have icons above
their head to denote which type they are
most vulnerable
to so our Trailblazer here is a physical
type with her baton and annihilates
enemies with that gray white icon above
their health
bar when attacking each character has
two possibilities one is a basic attack
the other is skilled and the skilled
Ones cost an attack Point seen here and
the only way to build more attack points
is to use the basic attack simple but it
adds another layer of strategy making
sure you have enough skill points for
your stronger characters and let's add a
third level to this each character can
build up an ultimate ability a limit
breaker if you would which can be
Unleashed at any time even if it's not
that player's turn to attack they can
jump the queue and bust it out some
Target one fo some Target the entire
team some add status effects some assist
all eyes combat goes as deep as you want
it to and we didn't even look at Buffs
debuffs and Trigger actions let's leave
those for another time the game does a
really good job at slowly adding to your
knowledge
base the playable characters in honkai
Star rail are plentyful each with their
own style personality backstory and most
importantly their weapon and fighting
press I found myself gravitating towards
the main people in the story thanks to
their quirks but rest assured there are
so many you'll be spoiled for Choice
over 30 the last time I checked each
with their own voice their own interests
and even their own Idol animations I
honestly spent time just watching them
I'm not weird I promise my favorite saal
a guitar wielding Bella Bogan will begin
writing song melodies when left
[Applause]
alone March 7th we'll take
selfies
Chee and check out our
character nice did she just say noce
noce nice once you've chosen your
playable characters it's time to put
them into a team a total of four can be
squatted up at once and changed out on
the fly your key focus is finding a team
that complement each other in battle
we've spoken about their elements and
super abilities but that's not the only
thing to take into account there are
also classes that matter hunai star rail
calls these paths but essentially it's
the same principle from most other games
tank healer DPS that kind of thing your
job is to find the perfect balance of
attack and defense because wailing on
every enemy you see won't work forever
March 7th here yes that's really her
name March 7th this gal can grant an
overshield of protection to allies
allowing the others to get on with the
brawl I will protect all Beauty in the
universe hky star rail can be described
as a GAA game but what does that even
mean well it's a reference to the toy
vending machine I'm sure you used as a
child where it's filled with balls and
you turn the handle and see what you get
Tada star rail uses that same principle
to make every unlock a surprise that
hope and slight panic when you see the
door glow a certain color oh and we
never spoke about pom pom some some
things are better left unsaid some
people love the unknown loot box Style
and others are not too fond of it which
is why guaranteed drops are included if
you're the most unlucky player to ever
live a five-star character is guaranteed
to drop within 50 turns of this gcha
machine and compared to other GAA games
I've played honai is the least stingy of
all with constant rewards and regular
free pulls relatively easy to obtain of
course players can speed up this process
by using real life money and my thoughts
on that have never really changed that
decision is totally down to how much you
value your time if you have the time to
grind honai will support you if you
don't have the time then monetization is
for
you alongside the main story line are
many side quests each that add extra law
to the world and some mix up the formula
too you can be playing hideand-seek with
children one moment ha gotcha and then
searching for these lovable creatures
hidden on a space station you'll
complete Minecart puzzles if you choose
to You'll unlock doors and locks via
this mini game and somehow even crossing
a bridge has been turned into a min Min
game in hongkai Star rail you'll Venture
into a digital realm you'll use secret
portals and you'll meet people who will
ask you not to tell your teammates
there's enough variation and option here
to keep you on your toes honkai star
rail does a great job of slowly
increasing the difficulty and the number
of mechanics at play after 20 hours
you'll be managing upgrades swapping out
relics and evolving your team without
even thinking setting your sights on
harder to obtain Loot and embracing the
grind during this stage of play I
noticed another great quality of life
upgrade up here is a single button click
that speeds up the game combat is
lightning fast here's a typical ultimate
attack at standard speed net markers
activated time for good old
Counterattack and here it is again on
the increased speed setting net markers
activated time for a good old
counter if you want to grind through the
combat the game will respect your time
enough to speed it all up if you're
playing twice as fast you can get twice
as much done in fact there's another
button just next to that this one will
automate fights an auto battler
essentially made for the mobile version
of the game but I'll be honest this
function is great when multitasking hey
it isn't good enough to beat a boss but
it will definitely get through smaller
runs while you go about your daily
routine two tiny quality of life updates
that really make a
difference overall hongkai star rail is
an amazing free to play game lovers of
sci-fi stories and strategic jrpg combat
will spend tens if not hundreds of hours
perfecting their endgame team over 80
million players are already in the
Galaxy on PS5 PC and mobile and best of
all it's free to play Punky star rail
will be here for years constantly
upgrading and updating evolving the
story and adding more characters to
master I hope you give it a try I'm Adam
you're awesome thanks for watching and
thanks for sponsoring this video Hool
verse I we'll see you next
time